she fails at dating but who cares she's
doing great in her career she doesn't
need a man but she's going to sleep
around like a man anyway she's like not
afraid to admit she like farts you know
you know this is like a very specific
sort of girl that was like really sort
of popular in the 2010s they had a manic
episode and spent eighteen thousand
dollars but who cares because you know
they're a product manager at Facebook
do you think that you're a pickup artist
no you recently released a podcast where
you considered that you might have been
a pickup artist all along and definitely
some of the insights that I've seen you
write
are unusually incisive I think about the
dating world where have they come from
why have you taken such an interest in
attraction and mating
um well so I have sort of a weird
romantic history I uh I got married very
young and then I got divorced into my
first real time on The Dating Market I
was already in my late 20s
um and like I it was like a crash course
and I mean it was the first
um
I don't know if relationship's even the
right word but my first sort of oriented
dating was so humiliating I became like
autistically sort of obsessed with
preventing that pain
um and I was like I I can't ever feel
like this again
um because I really felt like I was like
um but I was 27 and it was just it was
like the worst
and I think that's what motivates me
yeah does that suggest that there's a
some time and attention that everyone
needs to spend kind of
breaking up and making up and learning
those lessons and that it doesn't come
really as a byproduct of mature at your
age it comes as a byproduct of the
amount of times that you've done it
um I mean I think you just have to have
the you know requisite emotional
intelligence I don't think that
um practicing on people all like that's
also not I wouldn't recommend that
either
um because you know you become jaded
right and that's that's a that's a flip
side there's such a thing as too much
experience
that's definitely true two years ago you
predicted a coming wave of sex
negativity
I think that you were absolutely on the
money with that although it's maybe
moving a little bit more slowly than you
might have thought but I think that
you're absolutely spot on why did you
think that that was going to happen
I started noticing
um so the way I do my predictions is I
look at where journalists are paying
attention
um because I really do I still believe
in Legacy Media and institutions I feel
like they guide the conversation and a
lot of my predictions are about media
conversations as opposed to like
on-the-ground behaviors
um and so one of the places that
journalists scrape stories from
um at least when I wrote that I don't
know how true that is now is Twitter
right and it was very trendy to be
um sex skeptical
um sex negative might have been the
wrong term
um but it was I mean it's very slip shot
blog post it was like Cassandra having
visions when I wrote it
um
it was a lot of young people were very
sex-septical
um and you know it's also we've kind of
run out of gas on sex positivity so you
want to generate clicks so it's like how
is the media conversation going to move
and where is the Zeitgeist gonna move
um so it kind of just made sense for the
pendulum to to swing like you know when
we're at the point where Teen Vogue is
like the right way to you know introduce
your cannibalism fetish in the bedroom
right there's like so many things wrong
with that sentence it's like you can
only go back you can't there's no you
can't go further than that
yes Shapiro had a really good take I
don't think that he had a particularly
good episode at all about
um the halftime show uh that Rihanna did
but he said something very smart when he
was talking about it which was when all
the taboos have become mainstream there
is nothing left to transgress other than
ideological transgression and I think he
just means that once everything has been
put on the table like where do you go to
find the new explicit exciting dirty
thing
right I mean there's a two there's two
answers to that
um one of them I won't mention but I
think people have sort of rightfully
um brought to the you know they've made
it their their mission to make sure
people are aware of it um it's a little
more Sinister and then the other one
um is you uh you know you be Alex P
Keaton right like like you shock your oh
uh from family time that's a very dated
reference it's also a very American
reference I think that's going to go up
ahead in two ways uh yeah so just you
know you
you everyone around you is a progressive
you you shock them by being conservative
right I understand yes so like uh
culture becomes Counter Culture right
yeah okay interesting did you see that
lady there's a video of a lady floating
around saying that there should be an
ethical way for women to be paid to be
drugged so that she can indulge in her
Kink of sleeping with unconscious girls
um I haven't seen the video but I've
people who think that's not ironic
that's not an ironic video
I mean of course it it makes sense right
there's a market for for everything
a market for someone to consensually be
drugged and paid for being drugged so
that this lady can have sex fulfill her
Kink of having sex with her I mean is
that
that's quite surprising even even in
this era that's quite surprising
I I'm not surprised by that at all I
like I'm more surprised when like I'll
see Tick Tock sometimes of people like
cavalierly talking about like and this
is off the deep end so I'm just gonna
warn you about what I'm going to say
like very cavalierly talking about like
playing with like feces and sexual
situations that shocks me right like you
see a beautiful like 21 year old uh
talking about it's like what what did I
just like and then because it's a tick
tock it'll auto place you just watch it
like 50 times just to make sure you
heard it correctly
um but uh you know
consensual Roofing is a little bit less
fair enough maybe Scott somebody
somebody on you is less
offensive than consensual Roofing I
maybe you're right maybe maybe but I
suppose one of the things because I
don't use tick tock so I'm really not
tapped into what I know is now a large
burgeoning part of Internet subculture
I heard you talk about the fact that you
could predict what was going to happen
on Tick Tock by looking at Tumblr a few
years ago or that basically no one
should be surprised by the trends that
we see on Tick Tock because I just they
already existed what is that for people
that weren't delving the depths of
Tumblr five years ago what what's that
sort of horseshoe Theory so
um basic so so basically that argument
is you know people think that Tick Tock
introduced certain ideas or certain
Trends but you could trace all of these
back all the way to like the dawn of the
internet even
um like here's a really good example uh
multiple personality disorder right so
obviously this was a trend offline
um thinking like the late 80s if I'm
remembering correctly right you have all
these pop like psych books about it
suddenly you know you have like this
cottage industry of therapists who are
diagnosing people with multiple
personality disorder it's the you know
the jury is not out yet if it's even a
thing you go on Usenet and
um there's all of these communities
um for people with MPD
um and uh you know it looks very similar
to what people see on Tick Tock and
they're complaining about today they're
like oh kids are just self-diagnosing
but people have been self-diagnosing you
know is it's as soon as they have a
space to have these conversations it's
it happens right so you can trace it all
the way back to Usenet and then there's
like people have like personal home
pages sort of dedicated to like oh you
know who are your Alters who are your
other personalities and then it really
grows on Tumblr because it's just more
accessible and then Tick Tock is even
more accessible and more and more people
are online so it it spreads but but it's
not native to tick tock um which is I
think the big mistake people make
what's happened then is it more visible
on Tick Tock is it more obvious is it
more clippable and reshareable and
commentable
I mean I think it's it's it's
one more people are online all right
it's just sheer sheer volume
um the time they're spending online is
much higher and also like
I think we really underestimate the the
power the journalists have so when you
write about something and you have an
audience you amplify the effect
um and that's my big argument
um with Tumblr I get sort of I get
misquoted a lot as saying that Tumblr
like invented wokeness that's obviously
absurd right like Tumblr didn't invent
Foucault you know but Tumblr is like a
really great vehicle of transmission for
ideas because there was a lot of
teenagers who are using it and there was
journalists who were using it as a place
to get ideas very easily and it was
during the age of Click bait it was like
right when click bait started
um so you see
um you know maybe this is the first time
you're learning about transgender
identity and you're a journalist and you
you know you make 50 bucks a pop on your
articles you get paid a little bit extra
depending on the clicks and comments
right I remember there was one Outlet
where it's like if you went over the 600
comment threshold you gotta you got a
Bonus you know so you have to keep that
in mind
um so of course you you take these
little niche things and you amplify them
and your whole MO is to get people to
click and to share and people read it
and it mutates and it becomes mainstream
you also predicted the complete and
total death of the girl boss archetype
why what what what was what led you to
that conclusion
to say that other people also predicted
this I wasn't you know I wasn't a
Pioneer or if I was I was a it was one
Pioneer among many I love to you know
make sure I attached to everyone
um so it's a few things one it's it's
bird it's you know the trend burning out
um so it's sort of the natural life
cycle how long has this been going on
have we gotten everything out of it that
we can how much further can we go and
that's a really simple question but I
think again it's another thing super
underappreciated and people don't ask
that that question often enough
um and then the other thing is the way
our lifestyles are changing like you
can't really be a girl boss if you're
like completely alone quarantined in
your apartment
um it just you know other like if you
are
getting into like the Alice and Roman
recipes as many of us were at like Peak
covid that doesn't really mesh as well
with the whole girl boss thing
um it's you know kind of went hand in
hand with uh sex skepticism and maybe a
more
um like
uh
prudent
um approach to sex you just you just
don't even have the opportunity to be
going out
and and hustling romantically or
professionally because you're stuck at
home and suddenly you realize maybe I
should have been building my nest
right
how would you describe when it was at
its peak or the promises that the girl
boss meme was supposed to deliver on
how would you describe what a girl boss
was
um a girl I mean it was it's exactly
what it what it sounds like you know
women women can do it too women can can
have it all um there is there's there
was a aesthetic Dimension to it as well
um I think for some people it was
um like this very put together
um minimalist like she goes to the gym
she's accomplishing everything and that
was one sort of sub-genre of the girl
boss and another I think slightly more
interesting one was the the train wreck
girl boss which I think a lot of people
leaned into what's that um you know
she's like she fails at dating but who
cares you know
um she's like
she's doing great in her career she
doesn't need a man but she's gonna sleep
around like a man anyway
um you know she's like not afraid to
admit she like farts you know you know
this is like a very specific sort of
girl
um that was like really sort of popular
in the you know the 2010s
um and when I was like just entering the
workforce this was like what everyone
sort of aspired to be like
um I also think it's sort of like or you
know you know this like Trend I mean
it's a little old now but the trend of
like hot girls have IBS I think that's
sort of an outgrowth
you saying this as if it's something
that I should be completely aware of
that there was a trend of hot girls
identifying with that irritable bowel
syndrome yeah I think that you might be
over believing how far down internet
rabbit holes I've been I'm very online
but I pale I pale in onlineness to how
online you are okay so there was um
there was like a period where
um you know like everything was for hot
girls right um and this is it this was
sort of like a commercial internet Trend
so that means like you would see it in
like big Publications and like very very
sort of like normies like a younger
sister might be familiar with something
like this it was on Tick Tock so hot
girls are into tinned fish so and this
is about a year 18 months old by now hot
girls have IBS right and it was like you
fix hot girls in front of something
that's like not really sexy right
um and there was like a few things that
came up a lot but basically I think what
the trend was trying to encapsulate like
hot girls are just regular women right
um but it didn't really come off like
that uh but like the girl boss sort of
but the second archetype of girl boss
sort of did the same
thing right where it's like you know hot
girls could be messy
um without really like critically
evaluating that mess and it's like this
culture of over sharing
um girl bosses are in therapy and
whatever and uh I keep wanting to say
hot girls but hot girls or girl bosses
or whatever right like they um you know
they had a they had a manic episode and
spent 18 000 but who cares because you
know they're a product manager at
Facebook
oh my God okay so
it seems like the girl boss archetype at
least in part was
n't that much about romance at least
like specifically that was something
that was quite vacant from the girl boss
archetype am I right um it was part of
it but it was like a sort of a different
approach At Romance like you see sort of
in the late 90s and 2000s where it's
just like hopelessness
um and you know people want
relationships but the girl boss sort of
takes that and turns it around and
they're like so what yeah I'm sleeping
around I've slept with 100 guys who
cares right it's like it's cool and they
don't they don't want to catch feelings
and like
um there is this like very weird thing
that you'd see portrayed in media but
also like in real life if you uh were in
certain circles of like women clearly
catching feelings but denying it and
everyone around them sort of like
encouraging their delusion
um and I mean all of that is just very
Millennial and
um I think like you know again it's run
out of gas but also uh people are like
this doesn't serve us really
[Applause]
um
why do you think it ran out of gas what
do you think it was that stopped
that particular type of how to sleep
with him and not catch feels trend from
slowing down
I I mean
there's these these behavioral trends
like especially when they really are
fads they can only their life is only so
long
um
and like certain like bad behaviors
become encoded in culture and sort of
um you know like socially sanctioned but
the other thing is like people are
lonely and like you know when you're you
know you reach like 35 36 37 and you
just can't you know you can't do it
anymore
um it's it's just like it becomes
pathetic and you it doesn't only look
without it from the outside but you feel
pathetic
um and I think a lot of it's just this
cohort aged out of
that behavioral pattern you get lonely
um and some people are gonna stick with
the I don't need anyone but some people
are gonna be like oh I was wrong this
you know it's actually really hurt
what I find particularly interesting
about speaking to you to do with this
stuff is there's been an awful lot of
assessment around the subcultures that
guys have got going on mgtow red pill
black pill in cells simps Cooks soy boys
whatever it is and as a guy who gets
exposed to a lot of that stuff
I forget that there are a ton of
subcultures going on that also influence
uh value preferences and trends that
girls are bothered to about as well and
it seems like the the girl boss meme for
a very long time
and maybe still is now was a very very
important part of it
yeah I mean I mean definitely it I I
think there there are Oasis
um archetypes I think what's interesting
is a lot of the male ones are sort of
like
um they're empowering through embracing
disempowerment you know like there is
something empowering about just saying
yes I am an incel and finding other in
cells right or you know men going their
own ways obviously like a you know a
more extreme example of that
um but uh with with women it's sort of
like this delusion of empowerment and
it's still it's like not acknowledging
the disempowerment in a real way or
making light of it
um and not trying to to to fix it as
much
um there is of course like a victimhood
stance that some people
um went into but it just manifests in a
very different way
um I've heard you say as well that
there's kind of two types of feminism
clashing up against each other here sex
positive feminism and corporate feminism
and not always do they end up agreeing
yeah
um you know they there's like the these
things evolve especially when like
there's like intergenerational voices
um you know sex part sex positive uh
femininity or feminism rather
um push the envelope and it was
genuinely shocking at a time and a lot
of people didn't know what to do with
that early on like um you know you have
someone like I'd like a Tina Fey right
who was sort of like an icon you know it
feels so weird to say that now was an
icon for a time
um you know may not like totally
understand like uh at you know and then
like 21 year old Millennial who's
talking about sex workers rights
what's your prediction moving forward
given that you can update yourself now
in 2023 two years on from the prediction
of the death of the girl boss
have we got further to fall what do you
think is coming next for female
subcultures and trends
um I well I think that there is I've
seen like a lot of
um like very sort of moderate like
self-criticism
um and I think people would be surprised
like I you know I constantly hear like
you know the woke will become woker the
you know the left will move further what
you know using these terms very Loosely
of course if become sort of divorced
from their original meanings but I've
seen like a lot of more mainstream and
um left-wing women are uh starting to
self-criticize and become a little bit
more like walking certain things back
right like you have the you know when I
talked about the coming wave of sex
negativity I was talking about also
people who were
um maybe more extreme or may like
identify as right wing but I think it's
coming everywhere
um there's
um and you see this like this move to
moderation
um all over the place another really
interesting thing is
um you know when I look at people in the
transgender Community talking
um there's a lot of conversation about
um maybe being more
um deliberate about uh surgical choices
and this was always a conversation that
was happening in this community
partially because of like
um you know affordability but people
saying like look I got a sex
reassignment surgery and it didn't work
for me and it doesn't have to be
um that doesn't mean you're not trans
but maybe don't get it and that's a kind
that's not a conversation that you hear
talked about
um very very often right because the
conversation tends to home in on
um access and making sure people get
um that that particular type of medical
care but I think that's a sign of more
moderation is just pop popping up
everywhere another place
um you see is like people are moving
away from alcohol they're they're
drinking less
um and maybe they're not literally
drinking less like their behavior isn't
reflecting that but the conversation is
that is it is in that direction
um so you know those are just three
different examples of places where
people are being self-critical and
slowing it down and
um you know
being
leading a slower life or at least the
Zeitgeist pointing towards a slower life
what is an example of some of the
self-criticism that women have been
dulling out
um I've seen
um definitely like conversations about
me too
um and you know these are things we
heard from sort of like the dissident
Center so to speak
um and the right like you know from the
jump was very critical of of me too but
now you see from
um more at the center left and left
saying like maybe we we took it we took
it a step too far
um and uh you know being very conscious
in the discourse not to invalidate other
people's experiences but also like
walking things back and basically saying
would an example of this be some of the
pushback to these gym Tick Tock things
yeah yeah
um Western Caleb was also like another
like really great example of um you just
keep on naming people that yeah we could
be Final Fantasy or World of Warcraft
characters and I would just be going
along with it who is this
um okay so there is this basically this
this guy gets publicly humiliated
because he let on a bunch of women on I
think it was hind or Tinder right and he
gets publicly humiliated on Tick Tock
and a bunch of a bunch of journalists
write about it and a bunch of
advertising agencies and
um corporations like jump on it and use
it as a punch line and it just blew up
this guy's spot right
um I think if that had happened in 2018
um people would have been like this
guy's a jerk
um you know these women didn't consent
to be you know in a roster or like
whatever thing right and
um I think because it happened after
there had been so many of these
you know I I think there had been so
many like metoo type situations that
maybe were
you know on The Wider The Wider end of
the gray scale if you know what I mean
um there is more like
um what are we doing why are we
humiliating this guy like can't like
can't someone be like a douchebag and
like the comfort of their own home
without it being like a national news
story
um and I think that was sort of like a I
think that was like a pivot point of
saying like
we've been leaning into the victimhood
thing a little bit too long
um and when I think of like uh people
saying the mood is changing or the vibe
is Shifting those things that feel
insignificant actually are very
significant
that's really interesting I think I
would agree
on the the pushback against this super
overzealous sort of me tooing the very
middling ground not to say that it's not
wrong or you know like bag Behavior
but calling it me too and you know this
is the incentives if you think about it
for long enough actually end up aligning
for a lot of people to be on board with
this because if you end up expanding the
definition of what sexual assaults or
like me too worthy behavior from a guy
is to Encompass more and more things it
dilutes down the legitimacy of genuine
sexual assault and of genuine genuinely
predatory behavior it's the same as like
if everything is racist then nothing is
racist if everything is sexual assault
then nothing is sexual assault
exactly
um and I think that the people who we
assumed would never come to that
conclusion they're coming to that
conclusion
is it just that
after a while the incentives don't align
with it's no longer shocking for
journalists to talk about this sort of
stuff it doesn't Garner the same sort of
clicks it doesn't because people have
seen it a million times before and if
people start hate commenting whatever it
is that you do or you end up with a ton
of negative pushback like that girl did
that did the Super Famous Tick Tock of
her doing like glute bridge and this guy
looked over and tried to help her clean
the plate once and then she went to town
and then she got destroyed about it
is it just that it every type of
meme or subculture that isn't grounded
in genuine
truth or Integrity or alignment with
what happens in reality inevitably just
runs out of steam is that what's going
on
um I mean I don't
live yeah I
I'm sort of like live in this
um you know economy of of this like
click bait economy
um and things just run their course
especially if like it's just ceaseless
discourse I mean another thing I think
is that younger people are sort of less
interested in
um discourse and by that I mean like the
constant culture War debates
um is this right is this wrong is this
moral
um and you see like they're much more
interested in talking about
um Aesthetics micro Trends
um
you know nostalgia in in sort of a more
you know
they're just they just seem like more
interested in that and uh I've seen I'm
also noticing that like the Paranormal
is uh becoming like more interesting to
people
um so uh you know of course the new age
has been trendy for a while and we've
had this new age Renaissance like
astrology but I see like the difference
with like Paranormal being like it's not
about predicting your own life it's just
it's there's like a pure Leisure uh
aspect of this
um it's like this cultural exhaustion
that everyone has and it's changing what
people are interested in didn't you say
that manifestations making a comeback
yeah they there is
um yeah there's definitely manifestation
is is everywhere right um I don't know
if it's making a comeback but it's been
it's it's it's been around
um like we've we've been for a long time
we've been like living in this culture
of uh tell me what's gonna happen next
and how can I will myself into getting
exactly what I want like I think you
know like you know in the few the future
um everyone will be seen exactly at how
they want to be seen for 15 minutes yeah
something like that
you found an example
of some lady that said if your partner
is talking to you and they're saying
something that you don't want to hear
then block that sound out in your mind
imagine the things that you want to hear
them saying to you and manifest into
existence that they stop complaining
about the fact that you didn't pick up
the dog poo outside but actually how
gorgeous or whatever it was that she was
talking about oh yeah it's Bonkers right
yes yeah that's that's full-on bananas
yeah it's really CR I mean some of the
some of the manifestation stuff is
really out there
um I you know it's it's a helplessness
right like you just
um you know you want something so badly
and you don't know how to you don't know
how to get it and I mean I also think a
big part of it is a people aren't really
out in the world living a lot of our our
living takes place in front of a screen
or on our couch or how does that
whatever
well because if you're sort of stuck
within your own mind right like you keep
there's there's nothing that you can
actually physically do we're so cerebral
that changing the way you think does
make sense in that framework because so
much of our life is lived up in our
heads and so a little bit is hidden
outside yeah that's very interesting
um
I
I've been thinking about this a lot
especially to do with the rise of
um like male subcultures online
especially you know the uh in cell black
pill ideology and uh how it is that my
experience and most of the guys that I
know is experiences don't seem to
necessarily speak to the world that a
lot of young guys seem to be talking
about online and the reason that I think
at least in part that this is true is
that social media increasing levels of
social anxiety and a lack of exposure to
mating in the real world means that a
lot of especially young guys experiences
about different ways that relationships
can unfold are experienced primarily
through the internet and by Design the
stories that are going to catch fire on
the internet are the most egregious ones
about some guy that leads to go and get
the milk and comes back and finds his
wife in bed with the postman and the
postman's dog and then she leaves him
and takes the kids and his leg and a
bunch of other stuff
that quite rightly will get a hundred
thousand upvotes on Reddit which means
that Downstream from that
young guys who have no other evidence to
suggest that women aren't all like that
take that as representative of what's
going on at large and I think that this
is one of the problems when you have a
chronically online world you have no
real world evidence to suggest that the
thing that the most online people and
the most egregious stories talk about
might not be true
absolutely and it's interesting it's
like depends on like demographic too
um and geography like there's all these
like little things that change people's
bubble like ask a woman who's like like
a relatively attractive woman who's like
between the ages of like 18 and 27 and
they'll say like it's so easy to get a
guy like you know you could just sort of
it's like a conveyor belt ask a woman
who's uh you know 32 or older and
there's this perception that any guy can
get literally any girl you know
um ask most men they're like all women
are and they they have uh you know
that I hate this term but like a
Carousel you know the female alternative
to the the roster uh so it's it you know
everyone and they all underestimate sort
of like how their specific circumstances
also impact you know it's more than just
like confirmation bias right like if
you're a 35 year old woman in you know
upper middle class to upper class
circles in Manhattan yeah you're gonna
you're gonna struggle right it's just
it's like of course but um if you're in
uh you know you're a 21 year old in the
Bay Area well yeah the world is your
oyster
yes what about rejection sensitivity
what's that it's the first time I'd ever
heard of it when you wrote about it
oh yeah that that that's a very weird uh
article so that was that was an article
I wrote or I guess a blog post that I
wrote
um about how we experience like much
higher volumes of rejection that we
don't even clock as rejection
um and
um we're experiencing like micro
rejections every single day
um and
what might be perceived as an
overreaction is just like a compounded a
compounded reaction well um like so you
know you po like
there's all these like micro ways we can
get rejected online
um so then when we face like a real
rejection
it might feel like more
um more painful than it might have
otherwise because we're sort of like
swimming in this soup of rejection
um dating apps are like a really great
example of this like you're you're being
rejected thousands of times in some
cases on dating apps and like we don't
really appreciate like how painful that
is
um like if you're someone who only gets
like one or two matches in a month
like you might not consciously think I
was rejected every single time I swiped
but that's that's act like you you were
and like there's you know you synthesize
that information
um I know it sounds Petty but like not
getting likes on on social media are
like not feeling heard I think is sort
of a more compassionate way to frame
that
um being unfollowed or being blocked
like all these things they feel so minor
in the moment but when you like take
them
um sort of like holistically and you're
like all of these things happening um
and then there's like there's things
like even in the real world of like uh
you know someone you say excuse me but
they're looking at their phone and
you're just sort of brushed off like
this hap this is happening to people
thousands and thousands of times and it
has to have an impact on the way we feel
so there's a
sea of ambient rejection that just
happens yes I mean one of the ways that
the apps are designed is for you to not
feel the pain of rejection right I mean
once you're matched with somebody you
can message them and they could not
message back but even with that it's oh
maybe they didn't see it or maybe they
were busy or maybe they maybe they you
know got hit by a truck or something you
don't actually know why it was that they
rejected you but I do think I think that
there's some legs to that and obviously
the like the easy pushback is well we
live in a time which has got the
greatest wealth and comfort of any
civilization ever all of these things
pale into the background but I do think
that
in a time where people have got fewer
friends on average than ever before
the ability to ride the waves of small
rejections in a increasingly cerebral
more neurotic more socially anxious less
outside less exposed to Sun less
touching grass world
probably does mean that a lot of people
will feel these rejections and not only
will they be more exposed to them but
are probably more sensitive to them when
they do get exposed to them so I don't
think that there's I don't think that
there's necessarily
really any reason for people to feel
like if that is something that they
sense that's some indication of personal
failing on their part it's like look we
weren't designed to be exposed to this
many people this frequently absolutely
and downstream from that the number of
potential rejections that you could have
had in one day on the Internet is the
same as you could have had in an entire
lifetime
ten thousand years ago
yeah I mean and you know the other part
of this is like boundaries have been
sort of obliterated so like we don't
even realize sometimes like how intimate
we are with total strangers especially
like it's so easy like via text or like
if again like to the dating app example
like in the talking stage as it's
sometimes called like you know you you
open up so much and like in person those
are like hard-earned conversations but
they just flow on their text
um and then so like when you lose a
friend who's like just an internet
friend
actually it's like really painful right
because you you know you don't quite
know how to measure that intimacy
um yeah well I mean you know if somebody
wants to rail against terminally online
culture they can say look at how
ridiculous this is it's totally stupid
why should anybody be bothered about
whether they make or break friends on on
the internet your friends should be in
the real world they should be the people
that you care about the most but the
bottom line is that you need to adapt to
the world the way it is not the way that
you want it to be and people are
chronically online people aren't
spending tons of time in the real world
with genuine friends
and yeah it's uh that was very very
interesting okay so you you also did a
blog post recently which was like 80
pieces of dating advice
I found some of my favorites and I want
to go through some of these with you so
the first one is if a woman likes you
she's automatically going to assume
other women are pursuing you because she
thinks everyone views you the way that
she does I call these love goggles
yeah
you know when you're when you're
paranoid that someone's gonna take your
take your guy right
what does that speak to about
women's psychology is that suggesting
that you know you become besotted and
that kind of Jades your opinion of how
other people view that same person but
in reality no one probably cares about
your new crush
um you know it sort of comes so I I
wrote that
from this a lot of a lot of women are
um paranoid's really the wrong word but
like insecure right that like they're
competing
um when some when they're not always
um and it's like sometimes like I have
like tons of male friends who'll be like
well I don't know why she thinks this
right like she's sort of like the only
like I I couldn't pursue someone else
even if I wanted to sort of thing right
um there's just there because there is
no one else
um and it's like an answer to like the
insecurity in women but also like the
confusion from men
um like when you like someone you assume
you you see you see them with with rose
glasses right and you assume everyone
else sees them in such a favorable light
um when that's not you know that's not
always okay it's like you know uh I
don't know if you've ever seen this
probe of like no one wants your husband
right like oh
um like like the overprotective wife
whose husband is just like some like
random fat dude and you're like what
like chill girl like sort of like a meme
that you see in like TV and stuff
that's definitely something I think that
most online men's dating advice doesn't
really think about which is the
insecurity of girls that are besotted or
have fallen pretty quickly for a new guy
and you know
although
the internet and stats on Tinder may
suggest that it's only the top 20 of men
that this is happening to every girl
that's listening has fallen for some
dude that is a strong six and it's just
oh yeah look I I don't know what it is
about him he makes me laugh he's cute
he's got an interesting job he goes to
the gym he does whatever he smells nice
cool hair whatever it is that
they like plays a guitar we'll call this
like medium ugly right there's this
whole name medium
ugly like women sort of like I don't
know why just like you know he's a hard
six he's a hard five but like
yeah and that that degree of insecurity
is interesting okay next one not having
friends is a red flag talking exes
is a red flag why
um
I'm I it's you know it's conventional
conventional wisdom right like if every
X is a problem well who's a common
denominator
um and I know we're sort of in like an
epidemic of uh friendlessness
um but at the same time like you should
have at least one friend or you know at
least two friends barring extreme
circumstances like you know some people
live in like rural areas or something
but
um you know it makes it more difficult
uh but
you should you know you should be able
to have long-term relationships
convoluted dating advice for men or
women is always a grift don't let your
romantic life become a product what do
you mean by convoluted dating advice
um you know just like how every little
thing uh you know matters like every
little thing is a red flag every like if
you know move your hand two inches to
the right and it signals that you know
whatever like there's all this weird
stuff like that out there
um and usually it's just a way for
someone to sell a personality or a
course or a book or you know just get
attention oh because what they do is
they purposefully over complicate the
dynamic of how to get somebody because
that gives them the uh what is my
housemate Zach calls it uh it's like
secret knowledge or gated knowledge or
something this is he's got a charlatans
Playbook and it's a bunch of different
things that you can go through to
determine whether or not a guru is
actually a charlatan or if they're legit
and one of them is this
yeah gate kept secret knowledge that
nobody else understands and it's always
using terms that no one's ever heard of
before or that a purpose built to try
and describe what they're talking about
it is always very convoluted it is
always very complex
right like you you don't need to wear a
certain perfume or a certain lipstick
for men and you know when like men and
women both are actually pretty pretty
simple I think
be direct not desperate
yeah uh you know desperate is like
cloying and asking repeatedly
um
you know uh sort of being a hanger on
not taking signals
um litigating answers is like a big one
um and directness instead of saying what
you mean and being honest and
transparent
who do you think that's a bigger deal
for guys or girls
um I think both in different in
different ways
um you know I I don't think we talk
enough about like like women do this
thing like like drunk texting but really
they got drunk for the sole purpose of
sending you know 20 desperate text
messages right
um you know like counting the seconds
between like responses things like that
you know just just be
it's it's hard it's it's because you
think if you send a lot of messages or
if you like somehow some it'll change or
it'll like appeal to the to this person
but it I mean it doesn't you know and
being direct is always going to be
pretty attractive I think from both guys
and girls there's very few people that I
could imagine very few situations in
which somebody being more direct unless
it was first date and they're being like
overly they're over over sharing as soon
as you get past that sort of first
step
being direct I think makes a lot of
sense okay next one uh he doesn't have
NPD what's NPD
narcissistic personality disorder thank
you he doesn't have narcissistic
personality disorder he wants to have
sex and you're too available and on that
note you never want to be too available
even if the person likes you that's how
you lose your value that doesn't mean
you can't be a ride or die but
boundaries don't only protect your
feelings they protect your worth what's
up
all right so the mpg MPD it's like one
of these excuses
we love bomb
Ed you know like so love bombing is like
when uh you're
it's it's a clinical term but the way
it's used is like when a guy's like too
sweet in the beginning and you like you
know you are taken with him well even
said like obvious like Millennia old
tactic now that we've like medicalized
it for some reason that's an apology
right and just like no you just wanted
to you like you know it's obvious
um but
yeah be you know being too available is
like saying yes to everything
um you know uh again it seems so cliche
and obvious like don't answer uh like
what what are you doing text at three in
the morning but like a lot of people
actually do or like dropping everything
um you know you don't have to play hard
to get in like some Labyrinth thing way
but you don't you also don't have to
like put your own life on hold to make
the other person know that you like them
you can do that in ways that
um maintain your your self-respect
um one of the things that does Trend
um in sort of like dating and
relationship circles that I think is
actually really useful
is this phrase called limerence which is
like an obsessive sort of Love
um and it's not love right it's like
it's like the crush that rules your life
and I think that is actually like a
really good thing to be aware of because
that's you're not in love it's you
didn't meet your soul mate like you it's
filling a void and you're actually using
it
um in the same way people might use a
substance like it is sort of an
addiction
um
yeah I think a lot of people fall into
that trap
never heard that word before I got I
went down the rabbit hole of liminal
spaces I know that that was a huge thing
on the internet but something tells me
that that's like old news too
um yeah I mean liminal spaces are
interesting it's a different different
Lane but it is I'm aware it's a
different Lane look I'm just I'm just
trying to find Common Ground between me
and someone that is like the most online
person I've ever met okay next one
predictable is good why
um you I mean you don't want someone who
always is
um keeping you on edge right like you
should know how they react and that
works in both ways like what makes them
angry but what makes them happy you know
someone where you don't know if they're
gonna like you one day to the next like
that isn't fun
um and I think a lot of
um these this like advice that's about
like predicting and sort of like sussing
out like what does this really mean what
it like when a guy says X it means why a
lot of that is sort of like trying to
like rationalize when people don't
really like you or when they're playing
games with you
um you should like you should be able to
tell pretty early what things mean even
if it there are certain nuances uh that
vary from person to person interesting
yeah there's a conversation I had with
uh uh Logan Yuri who is the director of
relationship science for hinge and she
was talking about how a lot of people
don't believe that the person that
they've just started dating is right for
them because they don't feel a spark and
with other people they have felt a spark
but those people they felt to spark with
were perhaps unpredictable or had a
whole laundry list of other problems
what they don't realize is that some
people are just Sparky they spark with
the person at the checkout they spark
with the Uber driver they spark when
they go to the bar and give their ID to
the person at the front they spark with
everyone including the people that they
date and that having that spark
isn't particularly indicative of
anything but one of the most reliable
predictors of relationship success is
something called psychological stability
so after an incident where
um your
Baseline has been knocked off so an
argument or something sad or whatever it
is how long does it take for you to get
back to Baseline and that's a very very
reliable predictor of relationship
success long term
that's predictable right unpredictable
would be they're going to block me on
social media and the only way that I can
send them messages is by paypaling them
one cent amount with a message hidden in
the references
or
they're going to be uh straight back
loving me within seconds of this thing
happening
because like it feels like when those
people are odd and positive it feels
like more valuable for some reason
um but also like they're using their
relationship to fill another void
um and you know it's it's I get it it's
addictive right like these are traps
that I've I've fallen into which is why
I share my my knowledge with the with
the world there should always be forward
momentum that doesn't mean moving too
fast but don't let yourself fall into
relationship Purgatory men will take the
initiative if they're serious sure they
are insecure man but even they will move
things along
um yeah just if you know if you don't
know if he's your boyfriend
um within like you know a month or two
then he's you know he's not your
boyfriend and keep it moving I I
yeah I think that's very true and you
know I know from being a chronic
guy around the party scene throughout
all of my Twenties that the
the dudes that were reticent about the
what are we conversation
don't have tons of on average don't have
tons of emotional baggage that means
that they have trouble committing it's
that they're next thing waiting for
something better to come along or that
they're just generally emotionally
unavailable now again on average this
differs from person to person this may
not apply at all areas underneath the
normal distribution of
experiences
but if you are never if he never asks
you out if he never says to you uh why
don't we do this here is a plan here's
something that I think would be cool if
it's always you pushing to see when are
we going to see each other next what is
it that's happening uh I do think that
that would be an Amber flag
yeah absolutely when men are sure
they're really sure
I would say yes okay uh you can't
manipulate your way into a relationship
with sex if they don't want to date you
they don't want to date you doing this
is a good way to get used for your body
um yeah I mean and this is this is a bad
advice you see all over like women's
Publications or like women's Media or at
least you did especially in the 20
um the 2010s where it's sort of like
you could like blow your way into having
a boyfriend
but you know and
if you if a guy likes the way you give
head but doesn't like you as a person
you're just gonna keep blowing it you
know it's not gonna be your boyfriend
and it's like brutal but it's just like
kind of is what it is
wow yeah I think that's true I don't
think that you can sex your way into a
relationship now there's some guys that
are uh reticent up until that point
I think again looking around me at most
of the guys that are my age now you know
my friends that are between sort of 30
and 35 and still single and dating
most of them are their relationship with
sex especially casual sex is wildly
different so I wonder how much of these
things are just trends that occur when
people are a little bit younger a little
bit more emotionally immature still have
a greater desire for sexual variety and
Novelty and new experiences and
everything's just a bit excitable
um but I do think that that calms down
over time
yeah I I think you're probably right um
like who is dating advice generally for
I think it's for people in their 20s I
agree okay men drop hints about weird
things that into through jokes you can
learn a lot about people by what they
joke about pay attention then make them
think you're psychic by calling them on
it
um are people
um you know it's a companion piece of
advice to this is like people will tell
you how they'll hurt you early on
um people tell themselves constantly and
we just don't pay attention or we write
things off as jokes
um
you know if a guy like jokes about a sex
act a lot like he's probably into it and
is gauging your reaction and I have a
friend who at every party on Meetup that
I've ever been to talks about eating ass
and he talks about it in the most he's
trying to laugh it off he'll sort of
slot it into a job but it's pretty
ungainly it's pretty consistent as well
reliably I would go as far as to say
that I've never been to a party where
this hasn't come out of his mouth I'm
like
this is not this is not some mere like
Quirk of your language this is something
much deeper that is coming out of you
yeah I mean and and but people do that
with all sorts of things right it's not
just like the guy is constantly joking
about eating ass also like
um you know what people are preoccupied
with is revealing fruits and these are
again like it's obvious once you say it
out loud but it's easy to miss uh
um another sort of companion piece of
advice is if they think you're cheating
uh they are they are cheating or they
know that they themselves are capable of
cheating
yeah because they use theory of mind to
project forward what they would be doing
if they were behaving in that way okay
don't seek someone out who's like your
ex they're not going to be the same
they're not even going to be better heal
that wound that motivates you to have a
type
yeah
um you know if you
dated someone who was like a particular
profession
um it's not that you have like a thing
for people in that profession you miss
your ex and don't you know don't make
someone don't try to relive that story
and change the ending
um start you know start something new
okay it's always going to it's always
better to be the less invested partner
even if it isn't the more fun option
this has been old school dating advice
for as long as dating advice has been
around right like the person that holds
the most power in the relationship is
the one who cares less
where does it's always better to be the
less invested partner even if it isn't
the more fun option come from
I'm that I mean it it's just old school
you don't want to
it's conventional wisdom you don't want
to be the one
um who's constantly uh chasing basically
you just don't want to be the the chaser
what would you say to people that
push back with every relationship should
be equal everybody should be equally
invested that's a sign of an unascended
unawakened relationship between two
partners that are still playing a game a
power game of push and pull
um relationships become equal over time
and
um you know a lot of dating advice is
for the earlier on in the funnel and uh
you don't start nothing starts an equal
footing too bad
if you have to open up the notes app to
type out a message
breakup
yep
just say you already
took a turn somewhere yeah I I think
back to some of the times in the office
at the
events company that I used to work at
and the number of times that the guys
would be crowdsourcing the way to do a
reply from the boys that were in the
room like oh now Lads like she's
like she sent me and they'd scroll ready
to go look she sent me all this we go oh
you must be in trouble and then we would
end up helping them formulate a
responses they desperately tried to
crowdfund whatever the like way to calm
this particular outrage down is best
yeah that's it's never good it's a very
good sign no never date someone who you
wouldn't feel comfortable marrying
definitely never date someone you
wouldn't be want to be seen in a
restaurant with
um that was me talking to me
um because I've definitely dated people
I wouldn't want to be seen in a
restaurant with why what wouldn't why
wouldn't you have wanted to be seen in a
restaurant with them like they you know
where like fully realized steampunk
outfits or something
[Music]
but you know I do think there is a
singer of like you know good for right
now not good for you know for forever
um and
um sometimes you do end up marrying that
person and you're like you know in six
years past you're like what did I do
with my life you know so just it's you
know even if you're not ready for that
step it's good to take every
relationship seriously just in case
because you kind of don't know how
things are gonna go and you don't want
to you don't ever want to be in a
situation where you're making excuses
for people
um there you can be compassionate into
people's flaws right but you don't want
to make excuses and I do feel like
there's a lot of excuse making in dating
or it's like oh he sleeps on a mattress
and cheats on me but I'm not gonna marry
him and then he knocks you up and like
maybe you do marry him you know
that was one of the heuristics I spoke
to Louise Perry about where I was saying
if the only people that you ended up
sleeping with are getting into
relationships with were people that
you'd be prepared to marry it would fix
a lot of Downstream problems because uh
the alpha widows
uh phenomenon have you heard of this yes
yeah so the fact that um girls who will
maybe get sex off a very high value man
but that man wouldn't get into a
relationship with them then deal with a
skewed perception of their own mate
value moving forward which means that
they're permanently going to be chasing
down
Christine gray as opposed to
maybe setting their sights towards
something which is more realistic for a
long-term relationship
s women are delusional for other reasons
though because you know those those men
tend to make it clear pretty quick that
they're never gonna commit
um and it's sort of like hope is the
last thing that dies kind of situation
with that
um so that you know they need
it's uh if someone doesn't respect you
you probably shouldn't sleep with them a
welcome realization that they might need
okay uh don't date down to feel better
about yourself it's not fair to them and
it's also not fair to you
yeah a lot of people
um date uh you know even temporarily
like people who can be like
infrastructure for their self-esteem
um and it's it breeds resentment
um and then it also I mean I think that
guys can kind of can get like Alpha
Widow word right and that's way less
discussed
um Sometimes women just leave them on
but sometimes women like will sleep with
them one or two times and it's just
because they wanted to be with someone
that makes them that like reifies their
own value to themselves oh because they
would adore them so much that they would
get yeah kind of emotional support
that's the moral of that short story
from the New Yorker cat person that went
viral in 2017.
um what is it it was the most viral
short story of all time so like this
isn't I promise this isn't another
random
um reference but uh you know it's a
short story about this woman who sleeps
with this sort of like slovenly guy
um and uh you know she's she ends up
ghosting him if I recall correctly but
sort of the moral of the story is like
she sleeps with him because she sort of
gets off on
how much better she is than him and this
is something that's kind of missed in
the story and it's sort of treated like
now is like this weird metoo Parable but
it's not really that at all it's like
women will date down thinking they won't
get rejected and also so they could feel
adored
um but that's not always what happens
relationships shouldn't be a sporting
event to see how much suffering you can
withstand it's not getting better leave
while you can
yeah don't you know
want to you don't want to be with the
woman who calls you 20 times yelling at
you you know it's there's a Offspring
song where there's like a lyric that's
like the more you suffer the more it
shows you care nope
absolutely not what people use uh pain
or their ability to withstand something
uncomfortable as a proxy for how much
they care right I did this with my
business
I first started my business I realized
that uh uh if the business did well that
meant I was a good person and if the
business did badly that meant I was like
less of a person but over time I
actually shortcuted or totally bypassed
the performance of the business and just
went to how much suffering did I Endure
during the preparation for this most
recent club night that we did and even
if the event was successful but I hadn't
had a difficult week of work I would
somehow feel like a piece of
because the only way that this success
was worth anything was if I'd bled in
the process for it and it's kind of it
feels like a little bit similar to do
with relationships that what you're
doing is
I actually know I'm not sure that it is
so much because the reason that someone
sticks about
isn't even because they're getting that
much out of it if all that you're doing
is is permanently suffering
and I don't even know if it's more men
than women that do this I think that
this is probably
sex equivalent like sex balanced with
regards to whether men and women do this
the most perhaps in different ways I
think that the guys will tend to treat
the girl more like whereas the
girls would tend to be more overbearing
on the guy and and sort of more Naggy uh
but I think the outcome ends up being
the same
you know I feel like people think
they've invested so much time also it's
another component of it
um like why leave now
um but yeah just like putting up with
like anything that's going to end up
with you feeling resentful when you're
older is probably you can't always
predict that but sometimes you can
on that point there's a secular and holy
apolitical reason that body count
matters you start to get jaded after a
while being spiritually run through is a
thing
yeah you you people are very similar
um and you experience the same thing
over and over again and it it loses its
specialness right it is and it sort of
has nothing to do with like
you know any religious reason or
you know political reason like anything
about like dirtiness or whatever but you
just you run out of energy for people
um and you want to you want to conserve
your energy basically
I had a guy called Andrew Thomas on the
show a little while ago and he was
teaching me about a study that they'd
done the optimal number of partners that
people say they want their long-term
partner to have so if you could pick
from zero to a thousand how many
partners would you want your future
partner to have and the optimal number
for both men and women is around about
three to four for long term now if it's
short term you get a slightly flatter
people are prepared to have the same
amount but zero Partners was as
uh desired as around about 11 or 12.
so Zero's too few
three to four was optimal and then it
tails off back down to 12 which is
around about the same as zero I thought
that was quite interesting
yeah because I mean you don't want to be
I when you're an adult you kind of don't
want to be someone's first you know
especially if you've met them as an
adult but too many you're like well
what's going on there maybe a bit of a
red flag okay uh the most durable
relationships are between people who
grew up with similar values this is
something that I've seen time and time
again with a bunch of my friends
especially from the UK it's the people
who have shared interests similar sort
of goals a similar sort of world view I
mean one of the most again in terms of
relationship satisfaction prediction if
you hold the same political beliefs your
relationship is way way more likely to
be successful because Downstream from
that there are a whole host of other
things about the way that you viewed the
world the way that you do personal
finance is how you should raise your
kids the way that you should own a home
your relationship to debt your
relationship to death all that stuff and
you know if you do have incredibly
different values
I'd
I can't think of any friends that are in
relationships who do have different
values and it's ended up succeeding all
of them by Design have evolved to be in
a relationship with someone that has
them the only people that I can think of
that have different values are ones that
are going through a divorce or a breakup
yeah it's it's super real I I dated I
married someone who's outside of my my
culture like completely and I mean the
things we would fight about were like
were wild like neighborhood choice I
mean it was just like every so just
diverging on things I had never even
considered
especially given how many different
places there are that you could diverge
on all the idiosyncrasies of you and
your fears and your concerns and the
difficulty of trying to create a
relationship together and then not being
able to agree on whether you should live
near a park or an apartment whether you
want a garden or whether you want to be
in the center of the city
is going to layer on a lot of complexity
that you probably don't need
yeah absolutely and that's sort of a
weird I say values because like in my
case it was like a geographic difference
um that really impacted us but
um I think like it really does come down
to values because maybe you did have
this like there are cultures right
cross-cultural combinations that have
similar values and then those can work
but if it's too many differences and
it's it's very hard
if he texts you six months later and
says he was actually in love with you
he's horny if she texts you six months
later and says that she was actually in
love with you she feels ugly
yeah
that's just the support I suppose that
where both men and women go to what they
fall back on uh
the number of so again some of the guys
I used to work with would have uh 2 A.M
3 A.M and 4 a.m broadcast lists on
WhatsApp and that would be for at what
stage of the night they had got to and
you had decreasing quality but
increasing likelihood of reply from each
of the different broadcast lists and it
would just be a you up text that would
go to all of them and then it would it's
2AM it hasn't worked 3am let's try this
next one and then 4am was like
hell I'm gonna have to scrape the barrel
here and then they would send that
message
the worst thing I've ever heard
yeah I mean Club promo is not exactly
known for its um chivalrous uh dating
Behavior beware the woman who wants to
use you as a supporting infrastructure
for her self-esteem incels are right
about emotional tampons
are you friends or are you a reliable
source of mail validation I'd never
heard of emotional tampons before
um yeah it's it's a word from the
encelosphere
um and they I think weaponize it and say
all male female uh friendships well not
you know in the inside world is a huge
ecosystem many different subtypes I
don't want to generalize but
um you know they think that that
many women are just using men uh and I
think I mean I don't think it's all male
female uh relationships or friendships
but you should be cognizant of it
because there definitely are women who
keep like harems of
um men that they perceive as like low
value to uh pad their self-esteem and to
make them feel better about themselves
one that's very obvious if you have to
drink or smoke to have sex with them you
don't like having sex with them I mean
the fact that this is
even remotely useful wisdom I think
speaks a lot to what Louise Perry's been
talking about which is this sort of
disembodiment of women specifically from
having sex that you know how to sleep
with him and not catch feels is a
non-ironic title of a Cosmopolitan
article away saying okay so I'll try and
what like switch off any psychological
response I have to doing this thing in a
desperate attempt to achieve
Freedom which is like I know working
like my dad and having sex like my
brother
yeah I
threatening because a lot of
and a lot of sort of content
ship podcasts and stuff talk about women
dissociating during sex like it's just
like something all women share all the
time and of course like I think every
woman you know will experience it a few
times throughout their their sexual
history but like to be regularly
dissociated because you're that
disconnected from your partner and
you're doing it to pass a time or to
please someone is is like very very
upsetting
why do girls like shows like call her
daddy and stuff do you listen to these
do you I do resonate with them I don't
no I don't resonate with them
um I'm too too much of a weirdo but why
do you think the girls like them because
I I don't I don't think I think a lot of
men I think a lot of men like them I
think
um some of us I think like I listen to
it just for pure entertainment and also
just sort of just like check in with
like different uh subcultures I listen
to a wide range of you know crazy stuff
um I mean it is entertaining I think for
some women
um it validates poor choices to like
hear other people making those same
choices like call her daddy was Infamous
for um uh you know they were they were
constantly cheating on their partners
um and it was very like validating for
women to hear other women talk about it
so cavalierly
um or you know sort of like uh that much
that level of casual sex
um but I do think a lot of men listen to
those shows
um because I find the ones where with
more female audiences even if they're
that candid there's a they're softer and
less vulgar and or the type of vulgarity
that they use is like more uh wouldn't
be resonant to men at all
I don't I it I mean I'm sure that this
is probably how it feels for a girl to
listen to Joe Rogan or something but
I've I've given call hadani a couple of
cracks and uh I
I don't really understand like where
it's kind of like a little bit of a
different language I don't understand a
lot of the
space like the cultural space that she's
coming from and she's unbelievably
successful but I would be it would be
surprising to me if there was a large
cohort of guys that listened
but I'm being surprised by a lot of the
things that we're seeing on the internet
today so maybe actually that's not
that's surprising I wouldn't understand
estimate her appearance
um or like both of their appearances
because you know there's Sophia with it
you know Sophia with an F is a new
podcast for the other host
um I mean they're both like very thin
and very beautiful like could you
imagine if there was like two fat women
like it just wouldn't
you know maybe maybe it would be as
popular but it would be popular in a
different a different way and also a
different scale is there something about
that that uh if it's a two hot girls
talking about they're failing forward
through relationships
is there something that almost
legitimates girls that see themselves or
their insecurities make them feel like
they're not as attractive as those girls
so they go oh well if this really good
looking girl can fail forward through
relationships that makes my piece of
car crash of a level I feel like
it's less of a big deal
um maybe
um I I
saw the audience demographics of call
her daddy
um
I think they I also think there's types
of of hot girls that like there's the
hot girl that a girl would think is hot
and then there's a hot girl that a guy
would think is hot and I think that's
actually a really useful distinction
um and I think the call her daddy hosts
were more like uh hot girls for guys and
hot girls for girls
um yes I understand what you mean okay
last one when people give advice they're
speaking to themselves as much as
they're speaking to you that doesn't
mean their advice is bad but it's
important context
uh yeah every I think I think everyone
who talks about lifestyle and culture
um is talking to a younger version of
themselves either they're trying to
validate their choices or they're saying
this is what I would have done if I had
known better I think you're right
William Costello one of my friends says
research is research and he's coming out
of the world of Academia but I do think
that it's very much the same you know
most of the people that I know whatever
they're interested in it's because it's
got some sort of relevance to them it's
questions that they're trying to work
out themselves or whatever because I
like by Design what what person would be
able to dedicate many hours per week or
per day to writing about something
speaking about something if they didn't
have some sort of personal curiosity
in the game
what are you working on next
um I hell I have a lot going on
um I'm doing a project with my friend
Nama Cates
um about uh like cyber dating
um we're doing a podcast together called
we met online it's not launched yet
what's cyber dating is that where you
don't meet in the real world yeah like
you know all things romance and the
internet
okay actually it's much much broader
than just e-dating
and I'm also working on a um book of
art and and short stories with 2D Cloud
uh which is a really cool uh independent
press that everyone should should check
out
um it's yeah I have a lot of stuff going
on but those are the two two most
exciting ones cool where can people go
if they want to check out more of the
stuff that you do and read your writing
defaultfriend.substack.com
Catherine I appreciate you thank you
very much for today
yeah thanks for having me what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
me
ant